[Music]
what's up guys welcome back to
conspiracy corners today we're going to
talk about Bernie Sanders and who's that
well Bart he is the the latest recipient
of the Democrats [ __ ] him over award
and he's been getting in 2016 26 but
he's the latest recipient so he got a
yeah we got it again is he is he happy
cuz I don't know about you but did he
like well we're gonna find out tonight
because today is literally Super Tuesday
so those are you who are like birdies no
good [ __ ] he's literally the nominee
well it's gonna be that easy we didn't
[ __ ] okay so let's talk back in 2016
how he got [ __ ] okay yes we talked
about how the DNC we've talked about it
before we'll talk about again real quick
just very quickly the DNC worked with
Hillary Clinton to install a bunch of
people who allocated funds in a way that
was sympathetic to Hillary Clinton's
campaign and not to Bernie Sanders
campaign and money's literally
everything in politics and so the DNC
[ __ ] over Bernie with that and that
emails Bernie knew and we they had
emails that confirmed everything and
then Donna Brazile who was the head of
the DNC at the time she came out later
and confirmed that all this happened and
they coordinated it with a woman named
Debbie wasserman-schultz as a
congresswoman from Florida who was also
DNC chair person and so it was a big
coordinated conspiracy that [ __ ] over
Bernie Sanders campaign thank you so
pretty much they restricted the
resources so you can't campaign all the
only that they cooperated with the
president not the president but the top
lead of DNC but that Democratic National
Committee to make sure that he doesn't
win and the true head of the DNC
whenever a president is a Democrat or
whenever the true have the Republican
RNC whenever the the president is a
Republican is the president so what Joe
saying is right right like Obama was the
head of the DNC while Donna Brazile was
the head of the DNC if that makes sense
like they and there supposed to be a
fair playing ground within that group so
then they can you know go vote in the
primaries and in every everyone supposed
to have an equal supposed to but the way
that they said that the super-delegates
super delegate system is horse [ __ ] to a
lot of people who feel that the votes of
whatever state it is matter the most
like a super delegate is allowed to
almost do whatever the [ __ ] they want
they don't necessarily have to vote for
whoever the party votes for which is why
a lot of people myself included think
that there's gonna be a brokered
convention where the Democrats coalesce
and I'm only saying this because of
what's happened so far so far they're
pushing Joe Biden and then they got Mike
Bloomberg out in the wings right and so
the idea is Bloomberg's spending a [ __ ]
ton of money they had Tom Steyer and
they're spending a force out of money
they're all pushing establishment
positions while Bernie Sanders is
running up the quote-unquote left
progressive radical wing or whatever the
[ __ ] you wanna call it everyone calls it
radical I call it progressive and so
Bernie's flanking them to the left even
right he's attacking everybody from the
left and so a lot of people are saying
the DNC does not want burning which is
obvious because he's not establishment
he's not stablishment
Klobuchar just just got out Buda jizz
just got out why would they all get out
at the same time after South Carolina
well the big running theory is that
they're all doing that to coalesce the
numbers behind Joe Biden
so that Bernie has a harder way of
victory right he can't win as easily
because the people who are already
suspect the Bernie who are back in
clover Shore or backing Buda jej are
going to just throw their votes in with
Weiden getting Biden a bigger power base
so they can head off Bernie and why do
you think Warren isn't out yet like she
seems like she lines with Bernie morals
but then we all know she's probably old
you know old if she lines with Bernie's
morals how come she attacks him during
the debates and [ __ ] I think that she's
running to be somebody's VP and I think
she'll take a little to anybody's spot
so she's a career politician that
doesn't give a [ __ ] I think so that's my
she was a Republican before wasn't she
yeah she's a corporate media [ __ ] so
she can't wait I think for for the next
big big slot if you will so real quick
for people who don't understand what we
mean by old guard establishment
candidate all they see is Democrats and
Democrats they don't really see the
difference between like what we see
which is establishment backed career
politicians that's been around for ages
but don't get me wrong just because
someone's been around for ages don't
mean that they're also establishments
such as Ron Paul he was always against
the grain Bernie he's all he's always
been enticed
and what is the establishment I think
the establishment is the Washington
donor class the group of people who
always no matter who you elect they have
the same positions and they almost fight
in public but not behind the scenes
right they vote they'll just call the
old guard - yes they all vote for the
same things a que Wars and and war
economy things but then out publicly
they talk [ __ ] on them so they're the
trifecta of career politicians military
industrial complex and aerial complex
and everyone that benefits from those -
like the oil and big corporate also the
people from both parties who use
government to enrich themselves and
their families and not they don't
they're not actually there for anybody
else but themselves so that they we have
a super high we incumbency rate right if
you run for office and when it's 80%
likely that you'll win again so that's
why everyone's like well [ __ ] it we
really don't have any power in America
when we vote because it seems like the
same end result happens every time no
matter who you vote because everyone's
just doing a circle jerk behind the
camera yeah you make me rich you pass
the policies that I want I push the
military whatever and they go on a
circle but then an on camera they are
putting up this fight that makes people
feel like we have holes so that's why
everyone is giving such a [ __ ] right now
about taking down Bernie because bernie
is an anti-establishment guy he'll shake
it up who the Democrats are it's almost
like they're desperate right they had
eight years of Obama he does the same
[ __ ] as Republicans so they're like [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
he literally Obamacare was written by
the insurance companies they're going
who the [ __ ] can we can we get behind
and birdies there guys same thing
happened Republicans at Donald Trump
where they're going [ __ ] it we're gonna
roll the dice on somebody that we think
is nuts okay
and so that same Donald Trump came and
[ __ ] it up for old guard Republican
exactly and so that's what Bernie's
doing he is the left answer the Trump
where he is doing the same thing as
Trump he's literally [ __ ] over the
DNC by winning by winning against their
wishes and so that's why that's what
they don't like is because they can't
control him right so that's the
difference between establishment
candidate and anti-establishment
establishment candidate can't be bought
and a lot of these guys they're yes-man
that's why they love Biden they love war
and they love the
because they play by the old rules the
old rules are campaign for me you know
I'll put in the the rules and the laws
and everything and after I get you know
I retire I could you know join your
board of executives or whatever and they
have they secure their position and
enrich my life right and I use my
government position to do so and some
groups they use their during government
to enrich their families or to make
their own situations better such as
Cheney and Bush in their situation being
at war was at it was their interest it
was there they were the special interest
for themselves same with Trump right now
real estate keeping the things you know
keeping the mortgage low all that stuff
real estate laws it's his own special
interest but that's a lot better than
the war machine neocon Bush and Cheney
team because they were using American
lives just like Bernie's better than the
Neal live Obama war machine it's the
same [ __ ] idea right so so that's why
in a lot of Republicans watching this
like bernie is establishment he's rich
himself no you're not thinking about
this [ __ ] right like Bernie does not
take corporate donations like he he does
small dollar donations I think he's on
average his donations like twenty five
dollars or some [ __ ] that's all coming
from individuals it's not coming from
corporate donors long [ __ ] so that's
what's that's what's good about it right
is that you have somebody who's against
corporate money who's willing to do
things on behalf of the people and not
on behalf of corporate interests yeah
that's definitely the difference between
establishment and anti-establishment
you got Biden literally is visas [ __ ]
like right like Barclays all those guys
like the credit card companies and then
you have somebody like Bernie who's
running in a different Lane that's the
point what do you guys think is gonna
win I think that like today like how do
you think I think Trump and Bernie are
within the front within the primary if I
hadn't seen Donald Trump get elected
president I would have said Biden but
now that I've seen that I think that
Bernie's gonna be the Democrat
nomination I think he will I think he's
gonna defy all odds and become the
Democratic in Strunk because he didn't
get to in 2016 yeah and that would've
been the right like that sounds
interesting yeah
in account that we're filming this on
Tuesday video comes out we will have an
answer that can be like man I was here's
my big thing here's my big dick
particulars right
I think the DNC is gonna try to run run
him off the [ __ ] wall right I think
that they they think that running him is
the worst thing ever you've already
heard it from every [ __ ] hack Channel
right MSNBC CNN Fox everybody says the
same [ __ ] they all say Bernie can't win
Bernie won't be able to his coattails
won't be able to allow down-ticket
Congress people to get elected that's
what they said about Trump and that
didn't happen he won both houses I was
on Twitter the other day and apparently
I forgot what state recently had their
election but South Carolina yeah they
were all had zero zero percent reporting
rate but news outlets were pushing that
Joe Biden was in the lead and then you
look at the site and it says zero zero
zero zero zero but then it says winner
Joe I denied him without there being any
it says like he's a victor but still
everything says zero percent so no
precinct precincts had just closed you
know why they did that is because of
exit poll exit polling allows them to
craft a narrative even while polls have
you said polls have just closed yeah
they had just closed it just closed so
what they're trying to do is create the
narrative ahead of time that Biden is
resurgent all the things that happen at
the end of kiss that's what they did
with Hillary yeah they said she was in
the lead she was in the lead and then
she was and then and then she lost what
they also did that to Hillary and if you
remember against Obama I forgot about it
it's the same [ __ ] thing right like
Hillary had the DNC's balls and Obama
just beat her with numb raw numbers like
the way that in a way that we've never
seen before with social media with
social media and get out the vote and
and grassroots efforts right so that's
why a lot of people are going oh [ __ ]
the DNC is gonna [ __ ] Bernie and I think
that they're gonna try but I don't know
if the raw numbers are gonna support
that I think that he might actually end
up being them and if he doesn't the DNC
and the Democrats in general like as far
as the corporate establishment Democrats
are gonna have hell to pay like they've
never seen before
right because
were pissed in 2016 because they thought
that Bernie should have taken it
so everybody who thinks are like oh the
democrats are a bunch of socialists
communists now that's not one of this
they are at a wit's end they had people
in charge that they thought would get it
done and they didn't and I think that
both parties right now are very
frustrated because everyone wants an end
of the wars they don't end everyone
wants like somebody in government to
give a [ __ ] about them and they don't
seem to so let's just roll the dice on
somebody else and that's what Bernie is
and that's what Trump was for people
well haven't uh Andrew and Tulsi the
media destroyed Tulsi and and yang
remember they were blacking out yet yang
Hey look at real quick look at what they
just said about Bernie and they said
that Bernie was a Russian that Putin
wanted Bernie to win right oh yeah they
recently did they did say that and I
created that a month ago I said watch
for the Russia [ __ ] [ __ ] they're gonna
do it they'll do it every time every
time that you want to talk about
something real it's happening like when
the DNC got hacked
they say they blame Russia so that you
don't think about what the DNC got
hacked and what it exposed like how the
DNC [ __ ] Bernie only the idea that it
got hacked by Russians that's right your
minds only focus on this right and now
this you're talking about something that
Russia came up with aren't you and
that's the problem right is instead of
actually giving somebody like listening
to somebody you're going to wait aren't
you a Russian tool bernie is it Russia
Bernie a Russian tool see I recently saw
this [ __ ] about they they try to smear
Bernie too because he was I think taken
out of context again and he said Hitler
had some good things or some [ __ ] like
that it was a Castro Castro Castro yeah
he talked about literacy rates or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah right and you
know what I don't think it was the
smartest thing to say because you're
trying to win Florida right yeah it's
[ __ ] horrible
you don't say that and then count on the
Cubans in Florida to vote for you the
people who escape all that [ __ ] more
like actually the literacy programs were
about brainwashing people into what
Castro believe is not about slavery yeah
right so right but but just like Trump
you have an insane messenger you have
somebody who doesn't necessarily say it
the right way but people don't give a
[ __ ]
more they'd rather have their Durst
they're sick of the lies like I'm
[ __ ] sick of them I would have loved
to seen Tulsi because she's a veteran or
not she's a veteran she's actually
active military but the audacity of
[ __ ] Hillary's camp Hillary's camp
was basically going off and saying she's
a Russian spy Assad sympathizer being
you know it's like how do you [ __ ]
say that kind of [ __ ] so anyone that
they go after I'm very skeptical of
their camp because so anyone that they
go after I'm like okay
they're probably the good guys if you
say somebody's a Russian tool or Russian
asset like they say that about Snowden
they say that about Julian Assange they
say that about they said about Chelsea
Manning if you if you have given the
American public information that that
they deserve you are a Russian asset you
are helping Russia meanwhile China gets
through and round run all over all of us
yeah it was this house trying to see all
this [ __ ] because our corporate donors
are the most benefiting from China yeah
so who runs Congress corporate donors
both sides so why would they ever make
China an enemy that's that's the thing
that people need to focus on not Russia
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]